I thought like certainly most of my
friends the world was in a really bad
place and getting worse and worse then I
wrote I read uh an interview with an
American Economist called Julian Simon
in Wyatt magazine back in 1998 and he
said
pretty much everything you know about
the environment is wrong things are in
general getting better
and I was like no that's just crap but
he said one thing that really annoyed me
because by then I was actually teaching
statistics in political science
um and I always told my students to go
check the data and he said exactly that
go check the data and so I figured all
right that's a that's a challenge I'm
gonna prove him wrong of course he's
wrong but I'll we'll have fun so I
brought together some of my best
students and you know we bought his book
and we're gonna go through it and
meticulously Show how he was wrong all
kinds of places
turns out that much of what he said was
right you know if you think about it
it's kind of obvious most places in rich
countries the air has gotten much much
cleaner and in London we have good data
back from 1585 and the London air got
worse and worse and worse over the last
400 years up till about 1890 and since
1890 it's gotten cleaner and cleaner and
cleaner so that today London air is
cleaner than it's ever been since
Medieval Times you you need to know this
and we don't we don't often think about
this that mostly partly because we're
rich partly because we decide to clean
up London there is better today than
Medieval Times yeah and that this is
true pretty much probably not the same
exact dates for for Florida but Florida
air is much much better in the U.S air
is much better than it was Force four
decades ago because we've cleaned it up
for a lot of different reasons but
mostly because we're rich and we can
afford to do so when you're poor you
want to get rich when you're rich you
actually want to stop coughing so this
is not rocket science but we don't know
and that's incredibly important and it
will become important as we talk about
global warming because fundamentally
people think global warming just like
all the other threats is the end of the
world it's not it's a slight impediment
on the world getting better so global
warming means the world gets better
slightly slower now that's a very
different kind of worry than the world
is going to end is there any statistics
of what age bracket fears global warming
the most you know like is is there a uh
you know gen Z's or gen wise or you know
Millennials or Boomers or gen X's is
there any statistics on who fears it the
most gen Z is top of the left but no I'm
asking like is there actually statistics
so they it used to be that uh that young
people were it more so global warming
age Gap younger Americans most worried
70 18 to 34 uh 56 55 and older how about
the ones in between are they confused
like what about the age uh can you go a
little higher I'm just curious to know
what this okay there it is 15 to uh 34
so less and less than global warming
will pose a serious threat in your
lifetime well yeah but that's because
when you're
it shows that people fear it less yes as
they age than those like 55 and older
they don't even think about it 29 but
the younger audience 82 percent
understanding global warming issues why
is it that you know it's normally
younger students 18 20 22 that fear this
the most I'll give you my perspective
real quick uh I grew up in LA and he
immigrated to La
um and I remember growing up at the smog
in Los Angeles and we were born within
three years of each other and you
probably read about it that the air in
Los Angeles was horrible the joke was I
don't touch I don't um I don't trust air
I can't touch but the smog was so bad
and you can see the pictures from Los
Angeles through the 70s they went to
unleaded fuel and and other things that
happened with power plants uh San onofre
went online which is an old nuclear
power plant in Southern California and
so I have a perspective in my own
lifetime that I have seen in LA's error
get much better I don't look at this as
oh screw the grandkids I'm I'm out of
here in 40 years so you know I'm not
worried about it I don't look at it that
way I have perspective on Los Angeles
which was a horribly filthy City and now
you take a look and again the reason why
I'm asking this question because you'll
hear stuff like you know Greta talk
about in 12 years we're all going to be
dead and how dare you you know an AOC
gets up 12 years if we don't do this so
much 30 trillion dollars why does this
resonate with kids more than it does to
people who are older
I I think in some sense it's just
because they live longer they have more
likelihood of experiencing the really
bad impacts of of climate change but
probably also because we're uh you know
when you're young certainly I had that
experience you just hear all these scary
stories and you think oh my God the
world is going to end uh if you're a
little older you've heard a lot of other
scary stories I mean if you think back
to the first environment Summit in the
in the UN in 1972 in Stockholm uh the
head of that environment uh conference
told the world we have just 10 years
left in 1972. so you know we constantly
hear this and you know there's always
the next thing around that's going to
destroy us all and once you've heard a
few of them maybe you've become a little
more skeptical about the next one and
you should look there's a real there are
real problems and certainly it was a
real problem in Los Angeles with the uh
with the air pollution but we fix these
problems and remember we fixed them by
being smart so you know the main thing
that actually fixed the Los Angeles air
pollution was the innovation of the
catalytic converter it was the you know
because most air pollution in Los
Angeles cost by cars it was basically
the every car got its own little uh you
know cleaning facility and unleaded fuel
you know they're they're talking about
now by 2035 a certain percent of cars
and they're sold in California have to
be electric well there was a time where
they said by a certain date all cars
have to be unleaded fuel but unleaded
fuel in the catalytic converter you're
right combine two make a a huge change
unleaded fuel was a fantastic idea but
it didn't actually increase the air
pollution it but it's very very
polluting uh but it but it's not part of
the air pollution it sits on the ground
and it affects everything you uh you eat
and uh the vegetables that kind of thing
but yes absolutely so so you know so you
said you were saying so the biggest
difference I just sent you if you can
showed a picture of la before in La now
you said the biggest difference was
catalytic converter catalytic converter
it's a it's a thing they invented in
1974 and it basically takes out a lot of
the pollution from the exhaust pipe it
cost a couple hundred dollars so you
know it's not free but it's not a big
deal and we put it on we enforced it and
now the air is much much cleaner and
this also tells you how we fix most
problems we don't fix problems by
telling everyone I'm sorry could you
imagine telling most Los Angeles at Los
Angeles is that the word yeah you got it
telling uh sorry you can't drive
you have to walk run or something that's
never going to work right but you can
tell them put on this catalytic
converter and then we fix much of the
problem so instead of what we're also
trying to do now today with global
warming telling everyone I'm sorry could
you be a little poor a little colder a
little warmer a little more
uncomfortable eat a little less and have
a little less of all the fun stuff but
then we'll try and fix global warming
that'll never work you know yesterday it
will work is technology so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]